I like finding exceptions to rules the
sort of things that expose assumptions
about how we think the world works and
that confuse any computer system that
isn't set up to accept them like streets
have names right okay sure there are
some people out there who'll immediately
don't know see there are lots of streets
that don't have names in rural areas and
developing world or there are the roads
that just have a number or a letter and
some of you will go oh well actually
Japan most of Japan doesn't name its
streets it names and numbers its city
blocks and besides it's more complicated
than that but okay in a Western European
nation like Germany in the center of a
large city like Mannheim you'd expect
there to be street names now well commit
to the exception to the rule here inside
the quadratus of Mannheim the squares of
the town centre only a few major streets
have names every other building is
referred to by which square it's on as
part of a grid the west half gets the
letters A to K the east half L to you
and that's followed by the number of
blocks from the centre so the block over
there is c4 or in German safier which
explains why the art gallery on it is
called Zephyr given the German
reputation for humor that's a pretty
good multilingual pun none of the modern
mapping companies know what to do with
this they'll be fine if the whole
country ran on a different system but
mixing and matching in the same area in
a region that as far as most people know
just doesn't do this mother can't cope
Google and Microsoft get confused and
give each road multiple names Apple
insists that each road has just one name
and they're entirely wrong although it's
Apple Maps sir you know OpenStreetMap
which is community-led recognises full
of dresses but not the individual blocks
although presumably that'll be fixed
within a few hours of this video being
uploaded this isn't some modern
invention either this isn't something
brought on by future looking city
planners rebuilding after the Second
World War or 80s planners getting ahead
of themselves while the numbering
patterns have changed over the years
this bit of Mannheim has had some form
of block numbering for a long long time
why change it just because some
programmers can't figure out how to put
it into their database programmers have
only been around for a few years this
city has been around for centuries the
address for place here in the quadratus
really is just a number then a block
hi Germany even if some computers don't
believe it
you